Hola bienvenidos otra vez,
digamos que yo tengo 3 manzanas, luego...
luego, yo te regalo otras 7 manzanas,
entonces, mi pregunta para ti es...
la cual tal vez sea una pregunta bastante obvia, es,
¿cuántas manzanas tengo ahora?
Y piensen esto por un segundo, aunque tal
vez sea un poco obvio, es algo muy básico
pero bueno, tienes 3 manzanas y luego te doy
otras 7 manzanas y 3 más 7,
ahora tienes 10 manzanas.
Pero digamos que yo quiero hacer lo mismo,
solo que bueno, soy muy floja para escribir
la palabra manzanas,
así que simplemente voy a escribir la letra "a" como representando manzanas.
Inicio con 4 manzanas, tengo primero "4a",
ajá, y a esto le agrego otras "2a",
¿cuántas "a" tengo ahora?
Veamos esto, piensen esto por un segundo,
obsérvalo bien, te daré unos segundos para
que pienses en tu respuesta y tal vez... tal
vez para ti sea un tanto obvio, sentido común,
trivial tal vez.
Si tienes "4a" sea lo que sea que estas "a" representan,
tienes 4 y le agregas otras 2,
entonces tendrás "6a" finalmente, asumimos
que las "a" representan manzanas, pero en
sí pueden ser cualquier cosa, pueden representar
cualquier cosa, tienes "4a" lo que tú quieras
que representen las "a",
tienes 4 y le sumas otras 2, finalmente tendrás "6a".
Ahora, puedes pensar en estas, en estas "4a"
como... esto es lo mismo que "a" más "a"
más "a" más "a" y a eso yo le agrego otras
"2a", entonces, más "a", más "a" y bueno,
¿cuántas "a" tengo finalmente?
Son... son, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6... "6a" finalmente.
Ahora pensemos en esto de una manera un tanto más...
un tanto más abstracta.
Digamos que yo tengo...
yo tengo "5x", "x" puede representar cualquier
cosa, cualquier número, cualquier cosa, perros,
gatos, manzanas, elefantes, lo que tú quieras,
tengo "5x", 5 veces algún número y le resto "2x",
¿a qué se va a simplificar esto?
¿cuántas de estas "x" tendré finalmente?
Tengo "5x" menos "2x" es igual
¿a qué cosa multiplicando a "x"?
Piénsalo bien, piénsalo unos segundos,
"5x" menos "2x",
¿a cuántas "x" es igual?
Veamos, si yo tengo 5 veces algo
y le resto 2 de esas cosas, me quedarán 3 de ese,
de ese algo, cierto.
Por lo tanto esto es igual, esto es igual
a "3x", "5x" menos "2x" es igual a "3x",
esto es lo mismo que "x" más
"x" más "x" más "x" más "x"
y luego le quitamos 2 de esas "x", entonces
ésta se va y ésta se va y me quedan finalmente
"3x", ahí están las tres "x".
Bueno, nos vemos pronto.